[Music]
rumble boxing is the group fitness class
that combines boxing with strength
training its popularity and the group
fitness scene has grown since it first
open its doors in 2017 and celebrities
are taking notice walk into a rumble
class on any given day and you just
might be throwing a few punches
alongside Justin Bieber his wife hailey
Bieber maybe even David Beckham
celebrities aren't just working out
there they're investing Justin Bieber
and rocky himself Sylvester Stallone
have invested in Rumble the new
york-based workout is growing rapidly
with studio locations popping up all
over Philly to DC to LA to San Francisco
you know you're gonna get half the class
on the bags working traditional
combinations getting your condition and
getting your cardio in and getting that
all empowering just aggression out and
you know over here on these benches
you're gonna get a strong weight workout
so you're gonna do your squats your
lunges your curls your shoulder presses
sprinkle in a little burpees all with
you know under the red lights under the
black lights surrounded by a group of
just great like-minded people having fun
and working hard the price of a rumble
class is comparable to other New York
boutique fitness studios at $36 per
class but it could vary slightly
depending on which city you're in and if
a big class isn't really your thing you
can also choose to work one-on-one with
a rumble trainer to get more
personalized attention the
individualized training of course
includes perfecting your boxing
technique plus working with weights the
private training sessions in Manhattan
start at a hundred and seventy-five
dollars a little higher than other
boxing studios such as overthrow shadow
box which start at around one hundred
and twenty dollars per session
regardless surprise people clearly can't
get enough a rumble so my colleague
Kevin and I are going to Rumbles Upper
East Side location here New York City to
check out what the hype is all about the
class is 45 minutes and
made up of 10 rounds switching from the
backside to the weight side continuously
it was not stop movement if we weren't
punching the bag during the boxing
rounds on the floor doing sit-ups when
we were watching the instructor
demonstrate the strength training moves
we were bouncing around to keep our
heart rates up we started on the bags
and by the time we got to the weight
section my muscles were on fire but the
lights the music and the hyped up
instructor definitely helped me push
through from there we moved on to the
private training session with Noah this
private training option is one that
celebs will often take Noah went over
the boxer stands and the six boxing
punches for us so we can perfect our
form we've ended rounds of squats
shoulder presses and push-ups as if our
muscles weren't already tired we've been
through punches on the bag to say we
were reaching fatigue at this point was
an understatement
I love the class it was a lot of fun
there was big high energy it was fun to
go in there and hit the bags on one side
and switch over to the weights on the
other it was not like any other class
that I've been to where most of the
classes are just directed one type of
thing that you're gonna do for the
entire time and it was fun to have the
options of going back and forth on this
I love the high energy for me at
trainers the energy all around the room
the music was great it was just like
super motivating even though it was
really dark and he kind of closed you
off I did find a lot of times that I
wasn't sure about exactly what I was
doing because of the lighting so I felt
a little lost but also that was the
thing that allowed me to you not worry
about what was going on around me I
don't think it's overpriced for that at
all right I totally agree I think it's a
fair price it's not astronomically
higher than other places you're like
what am I getting for that money and you
just spend the same kind of money if you
go now for a few drinks at Manhattan so
there's something to say about the
energy of a class and just having all
those people around you and just the
whole experience of a rumble class
[Music]